hey thanks everyone so i'm going to
start my video briefly to wave high i'm
on a slightly flaky internet connection
so i'm probably mostly going to keep my
video off
um and hopefully somebody will let me
know if some
there's some technological breakdown
here uh but
assuming there is not for now uh this
talk is called robustly learning any
clusterful mixture of gaussians via sos
and the proofs algorithms method
it's based on joint work with ilias
diaconicalis daniel kaine and sushrut
khalimakar
the version of this that is appearing in
fox this year is merged with the paper
by anish bakshi and pravesh kathari
so my talk has two goals
one is to give some exposition of this
recent new result on robustly learning
gaussian mixtures
uh results along these lines have been
discussed already in
this um simon's semester uh pravesh
kathari talked about his joint paper
with aynesh
in a workshop a couple weeks ago and
daniel
kane has discussed his follow-up paper
which i'll mention a little later in
this talk in one of the reading groups
um i'll give a little more thorough
exposition of the results than these
guys had time for
and also i want to do something that
they didn't uh get around to which is
describe
this sum of squares proofs to algorithms
algorithm design technique which we used
to give these uh this new result on
learning gaussian mixtures um this
technique is
super broadly applicable in high
dimensional statistics
uh for algorithm design in high
dimensional statistics it's turned out
to be
useful now for a wide range of problems
matrix and tensor completion a lot of
problems in robust and heavy tail
statistics federated learning
and i expect that as we shine a brighter
and brighter light on
algorithmic questions and high
dimensional statistics we will see lots
more applications of this
of this technique those are the talk
goals um but to get started
any talk on gaussian mixtures we need to
define gaussian mixture models although
i'm sure many of you have seen this
before
so gaussian mixture models are the
canonical
model generative model for
non-homogeneous
data sets so a gaussian mixture model is
just a collection of gaussians
it could be one-dimensional you know
gaussians or it could be
high dimensional gaussians we will focus
on the latter case
and to draw a sample from a gaussian
mixture model it's just some probability
distribution
you draw you choose at random
one of the gaussians in this case i'm
going to talk about
mixtures with uniform weight so we'll
just choose one of the gaussians
uniformly at random
and then draw a sample from that
gaussian that you chose
so you can already see that once we
reach even
mixtures of gaussians in two dimensions
there are lots of ways
geometrically that said that a
collection of gaussians could be
arranged
leading to a wide uh broad expressive
power
of this collection of probability
distributions as a way to
model non-homogeneous data sets so i
will spare
you most of the history lesson on this
since i'm sure many of you have heard it
but
gaussian mixtures go way way back to the
founding of modern statistics by carl
pearson at the turn of the
last century they're now ubiquitous in
machine learning data science and
statistics
every data science package has
algorithms to fit gaussian mixture
models to data
so they are extremely uh well studied
the basic algorithmic problem for
gaussian mixture models
is the problem of learning gaussian
mixtures which
just means taking a collection of
samples and fitting a gaussian mixture
model to
it so formally let's actually define a
gaussian mixture model
the information we need to define it is
some collection of mean vectors
living in d dimensions and for this talk
we will always think of d as being large
so some mean vectors mu 1 up to mu k
some covariance matrices sigma 1 up to
sigma k
and then the gaussian mixture model is
just the uniform combination
non convex combination of
the gaussian at mean ui and covariance
sigma i
and the learning gmm's problem is i will
give you some samples
from some particular gmm specified by
these muse and these sigmas
you should find estimators mu hats and
sigma hats
such that the gaussian mixture model
induced by your estimates
is close to the ground truth gaussian
mixture
in total variation distance so we could
impose other notions of closeness but
this is the most stringent one
i don't measure distance between
parameters i measure distance between
the probability distributions themselves
so this is the basic problem take
samples from a gaussian mixture and
fit fit a model to them
and even though gaussian mixtures were
studied as i said
since basically 1900 or a bit before it
took a very long time to obtain
enough of a detailed
rigorous understanding of them to be
able to prove
to design algorithms with provable
statistical and running time guarantees
but the last word on learning gaussian
mixtures
is this theorem due to moisture and
valiant now 10 years ago
which shows which they give an algorithm
and analyzed it showing that you can
learn gaussian mixtures in polynomial
time
with polynomially many samples where
polynomial means polynomial in ambient
dimension
and one over desired accuracy
this is a polynomial time algorithm for
each fixed k for where k is the number
of gaussians
this actually turns out to be
information theoretically necessary so
the running time is exponential in k
but polynomial in dimension and desired
accuracy
so this is actually a pretty remarkable
um
remarkable theorem
and it essentially settles the question
of learning gaussian mixtures in the
model that i just described
i'm going to talk today about algorithm
design with slightly somewhat more
stringent requirements so i'm going to
talk about algorithms which have to
succeed
in the face of nastier data so i'm going
to work in the robust statistics setting
where instead of our algorithms getting
to see independent samples
from a gaussian mixture what will happen
is that some independent samples will be
drawn
and then they will be handed to a
malicious adversary who i have
sketched in detail here the malicious
adversary will be allowed
to look at all of these samples and then
modify
arbitrarily any small fraction of them
any epsilon fraction of them so
she can take epsilon n of these vectors
y1 through yn
and just replace them with completely
arbitrary vectors and then she will hand
you this list of
epsilon corrupted samples x1 through xn
so the merits of trying to design
algorithms which still
accomplish statistics tasks like
learning gaussian mixtures even given
corrupted data are are several um one is
that this kind of model
allows you to it gives algorithms which
succeed in this model
by definition will have to succeed under
more challenging circumstances
like what if your underlying samples
didn't really come from a gaussian
mixture model
instead they came from some distribution
that was only
epsilon close to a gaussian mixture
model this
you know is more realistic because uh
the war the real world isn't really
gaussian it's only close to gaussian
right so this allows
algorithms that this gives you
algorithms which will succeed
even when models are misspecified of
course by definition it also gives you
algorithms which will succeed if there
really is some malicious adversary in
the loop who is
poisoning your data and on a on a more
philosophical level
it kind of encourages algorithm design
which doesn't over fit to assumptions
about data sets
so one thing that we will see at least
briefly is that the moisture valiant
algorithm
um it in some sense even though it's
it's a it was a major
breakthrough of an algorithm it does
sort of overfit to the assumption
that the underlying distributions are
gaussian in the sense that it uses
sort of brittle algebraic properties of
gaussians to
uh to do to learn parameters
so that's robust statistics are there
questions about this model before i
move on
not so much by the way i have the group
chat open so i can see it if you if you
prefer to type a question
and if i if i miss such a question i
hope one of the moderators will
tell me okay so a little bit
of of context about robust statistics
before we state the main result that i
want to talk about
this idea of robustness goes way back in
statistics formally at least to the 60s
and informally it was studied
long before that and for the for its
first few decades robustness was well
understood in
in low dimensional settings which is not
what we're thinking about today
and was well understood in high
dimensions but sort of
non-algorithmically whereby
non-algorithmically i mean
that um people invented robust
statistical procedures
uh for basic problems like learning a
gaussian
but those procedures tended to have
exponential
running times in the ambient dimension
so
it took actually until just about five
years ago
to see significant algorithmic progress
in
for robust for robust high dimensional
uh statistics so we saw some
breakthrough papers
in 2016 and then these were followed by
uh now
dozens of papers giving polynomial time
and even sometimes like linear time
algorithms for
robust high-dimensional statistics what
i want to point out
about this recent flurry of progress in
the last five years is that
while not all of it is like this many of
the algorithms are for what i'm going to
call
easy problems easy is in quotations
because i mean problems that are easy
if you are not working in the robust
setting so these are problems like
learning the parameters of a single
gaussian distribution or estimating the
mean
of a random vector problems where if you
weren't working in the robust setting
you would do something
very trivial like use the empirical mean
of course these problems become quite
non-trivial in the robust setting
and a major contribution of this last
five years of work has
been to develop a bunch a big toolbox of
techniques
to deal with such problems
algorithmically in high dimensions
what we are starting to see now and what
i think this work represents some
progress on
are robust algorithms for what i would
call hard high dimensional statistics
problems problems which were quite
challenging and required
significant algorithmic firepower even
if you weren't
worried about robustness
okay so with that for context let me
offer
the following theorem which almost says
almost gives us an algorithm for uh
robustly learning
gaussian mixtures in high dimensions but
we will need one additional assumption
on our underlying gaussian mixture model
so the theorem says
that you can learn a mixture of k
gaussians from epsilon corrupted samples
in d
dimensions um in polynomial time
where the polynomial is polynomial for
each fixed k but of course we know
that's information theoretically
necessary
under the following assumption which i'm
going to call a clusterability
assumption
the assumption is that for every pair of
gaussians g and g prime
appearing in the mixture those gaussians
are separated in total variation
distance
they have tv distance at least think of
this as like
0.99 right close to 1. and what this
means is that if i told you the
underlying gaussians
for any particular sample there would be
basically no ambiguity
about which of the gaussians it came
from
of course there exist gaussian mixture
models where that's not the case
the reason i call this a clusterability
assumption is that this is the minimal
assumption necessary
for the samples to have
a unambiguous ground truth clustering
right
if if some pair of gaussians is too
close in total variation distance
then samples that come from one of those
gaussians it's ambiguous which cluster
to assign them to which of the
underlying gaussians they came from
a few words about the quantitative
things in this theorem before i move on
one is that you might wonder what is the
dependence of our running time and
sample complexity on the number of
gaussians k
so i owe it to you to to tell you how
atrocious this is
so in our work we obtained
the guarantee that this is this okay of
one term
is some exponential tower
of k's of height about k
so this is a really atrocious running
time um
it can be improved bakshi and klithari
i see the question i'll get to it after
this really quick actually in kothari
um we're able to give a better bound
they were able to obtain
k to the k for this exponent but
actually we know that moitra and valiant
in their non-robust algorithm gave
uh poly k bound
which means that there's still a nice
open question can you get
an algorithm with running time d to the
poly k in the robust setting
uh the question is does the moisture
valiant algorithm work with no
assumption on separation
yes so this assumption this
clusterability assumption
does not like moisture valiant do not
need this
and it's a important open problem to
remove this assumption and give an
algorithm which works for
every gaussian mixture model uh
that brings me to my second point which
is that in a follow-up work
that came out just a couple of months
ago daniel kane has removed this cluster
ability assumption
um but only in the case of k equals two
so we still need to see it removed for
for higher k
and i should say he did this not by
extending the algorithm here but
basically by designing a whole new
algorithm
for the case that a pair of two
gaussians is not clusterable
that whole new algorithm actually uses
what i would say are somewhat more
standard tools than we will use
for for this algorithm it uses some kind
of robustified method of moments
other questions about the theorem
statement
all right in that case i will move on
so i want to illustrate just to
for you to have these things in your
mind um
the kinds of gaussian mixtures that an
algorithm with guarantees like ours has
to
deal with so and compare them to what
kind of
gaussian mixture's prior robust
algorithms for learning gmms would have
been able to handle
so our algorithm will have to deal with
gaussians
which have very high variance in some
directions and very low variance
in others and you can imagine that in
high dimensions you could hide
a single low variance direction among
many high variance directions
and your robust algorithm would be
required to find some kind of hidden
direction
in in d dimensions that's one sort of
special case of this cluster mixture of
gaussians
another way that two mixed two gaussians
could be arranged and still be
clusterable
would be that they could have wildly
different looking variances in some
direction
so perhaps one of the gaussians is kind
of like a standard gaussian and one of
them
is very long and skinny this would be a
clusterable mixture
you could also have gaussians that are
um that have
similar looking covariances but on
slightly different scales so like
imagine two
concentric spheres and all of these are
situations that our algorithm will have
to handle
by contrast uh the best prior work
for learning uh gaussian mixtures
robustly basically required the
gaussians to be spherical
or at least sort of have an upper bound
on their variance a known upper bound on
their variants in every direction
and this is this is going back to the
last point i made on the last slide
which is that it's still
open to deal with the non-clusterable
situation in the case of three or more
gaussians so this
this is supposed to illustrate a
non-cholesterol mixture in the sense
that the pink and the blue gaussians
have
quite high overlap here so sorry
sam the two pictures on the top uh
middle and right why are they
clusterable
so okay they would be more obviously
clusterable if i had drawn them better
so this is this picture in the middle is
meant to illustr is meant to
you think of this blue gaussian as
really really long
so that 99 of the mass of the blue
gaussian occurs
out here in its tail sure right thanks
um and similarly here uh yeah it doesn't
look clusterable in two dimensions but
think of the high dimensional setting
where the mass of the galaxy lies on a
thin shell
and then think of think of this being a
thin shell at radius you know one
and this guy has a thin shell at radius
0.9
yeah i understand thanks okay great
thanks nikki okay so
i want to now try to give you some sense
of the techniques that we use to design
these algorithms and show you what the
algorithms actually are
uh to to do this with a minimum of
notation and to get rid of some
technical annoyances in the algorithms
i'm going to assume that the number of
gaussians is 2.
okay so i'm going to fix k equals 2 and
i'll actually make one more simplifying
assumption a little bit later
i just want to point out that even in
the k equals 2 case the guarantees that
we achieve
are our novel uh it was not known how to
robustly learn even a mixture of two
gaussians before our work
so the agenda for the next 25 minutes or
so
is i will give you an outline of our
algorithm
i will zoom in on the key step of the
algorithm which is a clustering step
where we take samples and
robustly cluster them according to which
underlying gaussian they came from
for this step we use this technique that
i want to get to called sum of squares
proofs to algorithms
this technique in some almost magical
way
is able to turn what i will call a
simple proof of identifiability
i'll describe what that means into a
efficient algorithm to identify
underlying parameters in this case the
parameters we will care about are the
correct assignment of each sample to its
underlying cluster
so i'll try to explain how this uh how
this technique works
and then i will describe the simple
identifiability proof
that we need as input to the proofs to
algorithms technique
okay so here is our
very high level view of our robust gmm
learning algorithm
in the special case that we're talking
about where k equals two the problem is
as follows
you get n samples they're epsilon
corrupted from a mixture of two
gaussians i'm going to assume that the
weights are uniform although we don't
actually need this again just for
convenience
step number one which is the most
important step is that we take the
samples and we cluster them
to 99 accuracy where think of 99
as uh some constant whereas epsilon is
going to zero
right so ideally of course we would like
a one minus epsilon accurate clustering
that's the best we could hope for in the
corrupted setting
but to start off we will
we will settle for just a 99 accurate
clustering so you can see this
illustrated
over here i have found some blue cluster
and a pink cluster
but of course my blue cluster still
contains some pink samples
and my pink cluster still contains some
blue samples
and i have to do this in the presence of
these maliciously
chosen samples here illustrated in red
once we have a 99 accurate clustering
then we can kind of put together
uh algorithms from the literature to
clean it up
into a an algorithm with the guarantees
we want which is that we it learns the
underlying gaussians
to accuracy uh to total variation
distance epsilon
notice by the way that i can't hope to
learn to total variation distance any
less than epsilon
because one thing the adversary could do
is take
the samples from the gmm that i want to
learn
and make them look like they're samples
from some gmm that is epsilon far away
from that underlying one okay so so then
there's some
some cleanup stuff which i'll walk
through really quickly so once we have a
99 accurate clustering
then we break out an algorithm from from
the literature which is able to
take corrupted samples from a single
gaussian
and learn that gaussian to
to total variation error so we think of
each clustering that we've produced
each cluster that we've produced as
being a list of 0.01
corrupted samples right because they
have still a few
a few bad samples we feed those 0.01
corrupted samples to an algorithm which
learns a single gaussian
that gives us some parameters for a for
a gmm it gives us a
rough guess at the underlying gmm then
we take the first guess at a gmm
and we use it to re-cluster the samples
so we look at each sample individually
and we say which of the underlying
gaussians in my rough guess of a gmm was
it more likely to come from
we show that this actually gives us a
much more accurate clustering this will
give us instead of a 99
accurate clustering this gives us this
should say 1 minus epsilon this gives us
a 1 minus epsilon accurate clustering
up to constants
and then once we have a 1 minus epsilon
accurate clustering
we then again feed each cluster to
the algorithm which learns individual
gaussians
and we get our final estimator of the
gmm
so i want you to think of steps two
through four as just some kind of
cleanup from our 99
accurate clustering to get to the right
accuracy for our
for our final algorithm it's kind of a
nice open question in understanding the
techniques
to simplify all of this to some kind of
one-shot approach
i said one-shot stp because underlying
here is some semi-definite
programming whereas this is all more by
hand
i think there should be some cleaner
algorithm that gives you that basically
does this all in one step but
this is our high-level algorithm are
there questions about this
hey uh sam um yeah
um our paper actually gives a one shot
algorithm for k
equals two uh for just for k equals two
you don't have to but i thought that oh
just for k
i see just where you do get the
you get the poly poly one over epsilon
running time
and you and the thing is that you just
don't need this notion of spread for
okay okay so i stand corrected thanks
anish so
um anish points out that his paper with
pravesh actually in the case of k equals
two which is what his focus what we're
focused on on this slide
does does solve this um this challenge i
give doesn't have to do
all this cleanup stuff so they are able
to use um
use the semi-definite programming based
approach uh to just
for at the very start give a one minus
epsilon accurate clustering
okay so for the
rest of the talk i want to zoom into
this
first step of the algorithm which is
this sum of squares proofs to algorithms
approach for
the 99 accuracy clustering problem i
give you n
corrupted samples from this mixture of
two gaussians your goal is to find a 99
accurate clustering and now i'm going to
make my second simplifying assumption
which is that i'm actually going to drop
the corruptedness
and assume that you just get accurate
you get iid samples
even though this might seem to be
defeating the point of the algorithm uh
i will i will say a little bit at the
end about how
about why our algorithm is easily made
robust basically because we will not
exploit the kind of delicate algebraic
relationships among gaussian moments
that algorithms like moisture
and valiants do so our goal is going to
be to solve this problem
in time polynomial and ambient dimension
with the clusterability assumption
assuming that the underlying pair of
gaussians is separated in total
variation distance
okay so that means it's time to
introduce this sos proofs to algorithms
approach and for that i want to zoom out
a little bit
from the clustering problem and talk
about kind of generic statistics
problems
so in my cartoon picture here i'm going
to say that a
generic statistics problem has the
following form
you are given some draw from a
probability distribution
p index sum by some parameters theta
and your goal is to estimate something
about these parameters theta
of course you might want to think about
this draw as being actually n
independent draws that are packaged up
into one big
random object but but whatever from this
from this high level point of view we'll
just think of it
in this level of simplicity for
a problem like this to make sense at all
a minimal condition
is that for a typical draw x
the things that you want to estimate are
determined by x
right it needs the information that i
see
needs to make the parameters i want to
estimate unambiguous
it's a small error with high probability
we call this identifiability of theta
from x and at this level of simplicity
you can think of
many statistics papers as basically you
know picking some particular
model or probability distributions to
study
and giving mathematical arguments that
excuse me that those models are
identifiable
right this is this is the mathematical
content of many statistics papers which
analyze some kind of estimator
in some kind of statistics problem
notably
such mathematical proofs unless you are
explicitly paying attention to algorithm
design while you do them
typically lead to non-algorithmic
estimation strategies which is to say
that especially in high dimensional
settings where
theta and x are high dimensional objects
they will
give you some kind of procedure that you
could conduct to
take x and find some estimator for theta
but that procedure will often involve
some kind of brute force search
in high dimensions like maybe you have
to maximize find the maximum
on a likelihood surface but this is some
non-convex problem that you can't hope
to solve in polynomial
time so when one wants to do
algorithms for high dimensional
statistics very often what you do
is throw out your mathematical
understanding of the problem that you
obtained by
studying identifiability and start from
scratch right you go to the algorithmic
tool kit
you see what tools you can put together
to try to design some algorithm you have
to be very creative and you don't get to
exploit
the kind of insights that you already
got by studying the problem from an
identifiability standpoint
the proofs to algorithms technique gives
you some way to exploit the insights
that you obtained when studying
identifiability
to design algorithms
in particular what it will do is it will
take a proof of identifiability that is
sufficiently simple
where simple means that it can be
encoded in a certain restricted proof
system this will be the sum of squares
proof system
and in a mechanical way it will produce
a polynomial time algorithm
that takes x and estimates theta this
algorithm will be based on semi-definite
programming
so to explain the technique i need to
give you at least in a
somewhat less mysterious way i need to
give you a crash course on these things
called sum of squares proofs
so leaving behind statistics for just a
second we need to talk about
a restricted proof system
this restricted proof system is a proof
system for statements
of the following form mathematical
statements of the following form
for some multivariate polynomials with
real coefficients
p1 through pm in some variables x that
think of x as really being like
x1 through xn it's a lot of variables
the mathematical statement would say
something like if p1 through pm
are non-negative at x then some other
polynomial q
is non-negative at x so you can see
a one-variable version illustrated over
here
notice that wherever the pink polynomial
is non-negative also the blue polynomial
is non-negative
a sum of squares proof of an implication
like this
is the following object you take q
and you write it as this kind of
expression
each of these yellow polynomials is a
sum of squares of other polynomials so
uh s of x this is equal to sum of let's
say
a i of x squared where i runs you know
from 1
to some number or this will be
polynomial in the number of variables
so what do you do you take q and you
write it as a sum of squares polynomial
plus some other sum of squares
polynomial times p1
up to maybe some sum of squares
polynomial times pm
and then you take all products of two of
the ps and you are allowed to multiply
each of those by a sum of squares
polynomial and so on
so why does this the existence of all of
these sum of squares polynomials
certify this mathematical implication
well if you take any point x such that
all of the p's are non-negative
you can just plug that into this this
big expression over here
each of the pink numbers will be
non-negative over the reals
any square polynomial is non-negative so
all of the yellow polynomials are always
non-negative
and that means that this right hand side
is always non-negative at any x such
that the pinks the pink polynomials are
non-negative
so this is the sum of squares proof it
turns out
even though these things look like they
might be very special
up to a few quibbles about exactly the
right definition maybe
maybe you need a small modification of
this definition but it turns out
that every mathematical statement of
this form actually has a sum of squares
proof
this is a remarkable fact this is a
complete proof system
for statements of this form so it's very
powerful
but we will need a notion of a simple
sum of squares proof
to exploit for algorithmic purposes and
our notion of simplicity is going to be
the degree of the polynomials which
appear
on the right hand side so if all of
these expressions
all of these guys have degree at most r
then we will say that this is a degree
r sum of squares proof
okay here's my here's just my my sales
pitch really quickly
so even though these things might look
special and like they're difficult to
construct
it actually turns out that we never
really construct them in the way i
showed you on the previous slide in this
sort of one-shot approach
actually you can conf you can construct
them in a composable way
so you take you give some of squares
proofs of small facts
and put them together to give sum of
squares proofs of of more complicated
ones
so lots of very useful mathematical
inequalities that you can use to
construct proofs of interesting
statements
have sum of squares proofs not just not
only do they have sum of squares proofs
they have simple sum of squares proofs
of constant degree as the number of
variables goes to infinity
so statements like the koshi schwarz
inequality the triangle inequality
the am gm inequality which we use all
the time and
fancier statements like hyper
contractivity over the hypercube
and so on all of these turn out to have
constant degree sum of squares proofs
constant degree proofs is what we will
be interested in because they will turn
out to give us
polynomial time algorithms
questions about sos proofs
uh maybe i can ask about the hyper
contractivity because i
it's hard to imagine so for a version
where it's between two norms which are
not
integer what sort of degree would show
up in the polynomial
uh that is a good question actually i
don't two norms which are not integer
okay i don't remember off the top of my
head the exact state of affairs
for hyper contractivity in that setting
uh it might be that we don't even know
it it might be that we only know it for
for
integer cases at very least you need to
get degree high enough to you know think
of the norms as being rational numbers
and you need to you surely should need
to clear the denominators
okay and if it's if it's for like just a
two to four then
then what would it look like then what
would the degree of the proof be you're
saying
uh yeah i think in the case of two to
four
the degree should be i would have to go
look at the paper it's like eight or
twelve or something it's not
oh it's i don't think anybody ever tried
yeah i don't think anybody ever tried to
optimize it very heavily
okay but it really shouldn't be huge
okay
um actually that's that the case of two
to four appears in this
um i can i can give a reference to that
paper at the end it's
it's very simple the argument and it's
some very nice example of a
sum of squares proof that's quite nice
to read okay thanks
okay and actually we will
i'm not going to get to the point of
explaining exactly how but
we will need we need to exploit hyper
contractivity over gaussian space
to give our algorithms
and my airplay has crashed so if you
will just give me a second to reboot it
maybe somebody has a similarly excellent
question while we wait for this thing to
come back up
okay looks like we're back all right
so now i want to go back to the
clustering problem and discuss how we
will use this
sum of squares proof technology to
design an algorithm for clustering of
course
i didn't quite give you a i didn't yet
tell you
how some of square's proofs relate to
algorithms
um i'm going to have to i'm going to
illustrate that via this example
so uh the the basic principle as i said
is that you we want to give some sum of
squares proof of identifiability
and then we will feed this proof into
some magic black box which i'll open for
you at the end
and out will come a polynomial time
algorithm
so first of all what do we mean by
identifiability well identifiability is
that samples determine parameters
in this case for the clustering problem
what are the parameters we're interested
in
we're interested in the correct
assignment of samples to clusters
so what i need to show for my
identifiability statement will be
something like given epsilon corrupted
samples or
actually i'm going to drop the epsilon
correctness for simplicity so given
n independent samples i want to prove
that the
uh that the ground truth clustering of
those samples is identifiable
meaning ground truth clustering means
the correct assignment of each sample
to the underlying gaussian that it came
from
so here is the mathematical statement
of identifiability that i'm going to use
i haven't yet made it a sum of squares
statement well i'll show you how to do
that in the next step but here's how i
will phrase identifiability
mathematically
it is a fact that i will discuss a
little bit at the end how to prove
that if you take a subset s
of half of your samples and
all of s's constant degree moments look
gaussian i'll explain what that means
then
up to small error s is one of the ground
truth clusters
looks gaussian means that the moments at
least
approximately obey the kind of
relationships that we know hold
among the moments of a gaussian where
here i'm looking at the empirical
moments
of the set s so for instance we would
require that for every direction v
that the fourth moment of this of the
set s projected in the direction v
is roughly three times the second moment
of uh
x of x of s projected in v squared
right now i promised you that we won't
use brittle algebraic relationships
among moments
and so what i'm hiding here is what this
notion of approximateness is
and all i'm going to be able to say
because of time is that the notion of
approximateness that we can
handle here is much looser than what
would be required by
by an algorithm like moisture and
valiance
okay so it turns out so it's a fact that
if you take any
subset of samples that has gaussian
looking moments it's a true cluster
just to illustrate what this has to rule
out in order to prove a fact like this
we have to rule out that if you take a
list of samples from these two gaussians
normal mu one sigma one normal mu two
sigma 2
we have to rule out the possibility that
you could take
a subset of those samples that is split
across the ground truth clusters right
some of them from my blue cluster
some of them from my pink cluster and
nonetheless come up with some set that
looks like it has gaussian moments we
have to show that any set like this
has some moment that fails to be
gaussian so we're able to prove
to prove this statement mathematically
i'll show you a little bit later on how
we do it
but of course this is just mathematical
identifiability this doesn't tell me
anything about algorithms
now what does it mean to encode this as
a sum of squares statement of
identifiability
well first what we're going to do is
encode this
we're going to encode this condition on
a set s
in terms of polynomial inequalities
okay so i will introduce some
indeterminants some variables let's call
them w1 through wn
and i will think of them as selecting
variables or assignment variables i'm
going to think of them as 0 1 variables
which are one
just in case i chose to include the i
sample in my set s so w
i is like the indicator for the i sample
and then i will cook up some polynomials
with real coefficients that are
non-negative
at a point w if and only if
these w's represent a set s that has my
gaussian moment's property
okay so you can imagine that to do this
you would do things like
write down the empirical moments of your
set s
as polynomials in the w variables so for
instance the empirical second moment
of the set s you know is going to look
something like this
some maybe one over n sum of w
i x i x i transpose
right this is a this is the second
moment matrix of my
set of samples s because the w's are
zero when i don't include
x i in in my set
so i'll cook up a whole bunch of
polynomials like this using expressions
like this and such that these guys are
non-negative only if
s represents a set or a w represents a
set of samples s with gaussian moments
and then i will i will give a sum of
squares proof
of the implication from my from my fact
so i phrased the first half of the
fact as some some business about
polynomials
i just need to be able to phrase the
second part of my fact as something
about polynomials and for that there's
something simple i can do
i will phrase s being close to one of
the ground truth clusters
as this inequality let me walk through
what this says
this says if you take the intersection
of the set s
represented by the zero one indicators
for s
with the samples from the first cluster
and you multiply that intersection size
with the number of guys in
s that come from the second cluster that
this product has to be small
where small is like 0.01 times n squared
don't worry about the n squared that's
just the correct scaling for this
focus on the 0.01 and what that means
of course if the product of two
polynomials is small it means that one
of the polynomials has to be
small and that says that my set of
samples
s as represented by these w variables
has small intersection
with one of the ground truth clusters
and therefore has to have large
intersection with the other ground truth
cluster
okay so this is a statement about of
implications of polynomials of the kind
that one can
prove using sum of squares proofs it
captures this identifiability fact
and the main technical content of our
paper is to give
a constant degree sum of squares proof
of this fact
of this of this polynomial implication
that is what i mean
by a sum of squares proof of
identifiability
then we take this sum of squares proof
of identifiability
uh we put it into this magic box called
proof's algorithm
i think there's a question in the chat
that was not addressed
oh sorry uh thanks very much yeah nike
asks
does x have two different meanings on
the slide by which i assume
the previous slide is meant no so
x here always remain always means the
data unless i'm
missing something yeah so
x in these polynomials yeah good
question sorry so the indeterminants in
these polynomials are really the w's
those are the ones i'm focused on w's
are the assignment variables that say do
i include sample
sample x i in my set but as i
pointed out on the previous slide
in order to capture this notion that s
has gaussian moments
you know the polynomials need to look at
the samples as well so
in fact they will be polynomials in both
these w variables and in the samples x
so that i can write expressions like
this does that answer the question nike
uh yeah so the the coefficients are
dependent on x and the
yeah that's that's that's another way to
put it is it the coefficients so it
i wouldn't really have to use this
algorithmically they don't have to be
polynomials in the x's
i would be allowed to have the
polynomials depend how to
have them be polynomials only in the w's
but depend in some other way on the x's
uh as it turns out i believe anish can
correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
they are actually also polynomials in
the x's
i see but if you had a like a more a
heavy-tailed distribution you might do
something
else yeah maybe you would yeah exactly
maybe you would cut off some samples or
do you do something else that's right
okay thanks thanks
okay so we take uh we take this
polynomial we take this polynomial
implication
we plug it into this magic box and i'm
going to open for you in just a second
and what we get out is a polynomial time
algorithm to solve this 99
accuracy clustering problem
so now would be a good moment for
questions on this high level scheme and
then i'm going to fill out a couple of
details on
on each of these steps yes sir is it
possible to describe intuitively what is
your algorithm without using this d2l to
sls
yeah i think the best intuitive
explanation i can give and i will i will
say this
a little bit on the next slide is that
what comes out of this is a clustering
sdp
so you could imagine some semi-definite
program
uh which tries to find a clustering that
looks good
according to some notion of goodness
right our notion of goodness is going to
have to do with this
gaussian moments but basically okay
sorry let me let me back
up you know you want to solve the
problem of finding a set of samples with
gaussian moments
right whose empirical moments look
gaussian
our algorithm will is is some
semi-definite program
some semi-definite programming
relaxation for the non-convex problem
of finding such a subset if you had to
come up with that semi-definite program
yourself
it's very unlikely you would arrive at
the one that we did because it's
a gigantic stp it has many many
variables it has very complicated
constraints
and so this stone squares proof detour
is a way
to arrive at the the sort of right sdp
or an stp that we can prove will work
but at the end of the day this is some
stp whose solutions
uh are relaxations of clusterings right
the zero one solutions of this stp are
clusterings
and the stp is some relaxation of that
other questions so i'm gonna i'm gonna
say a little bit more about what
what is up with this stp
so let me do two things uh here at the
end of the talk
one is go inside this box to give you
some more intuitive sense of what the
algorithm is and then the last one
is i didn't actually tell you how to
prove this kind of identifiability
statement which
in the end is really the technical
content of our paper so i'll try to give
you some idea of actually how to how to
prove this
so what is going on inside the proof's
algorithms box and here i just want to
mention that
i'm doing this all in the setting of
this gaussian mixture clustering problem
but this
this is completely generic this is
you know any problem that where you can
capture identifiability in terms of
these polynomial implications
you can hope to use this same technology
so we know we have from from our
formulations
and over the last few slides we have
some collection of polynomials
that are non-zero if and only if w
represents
uh a good subset s a subset with
gaussian moments
and we know that a good subset a subset
with gaussian moments is
close to a ground truth cluster so that
means
that if i showed you these the system of
polynomials what you want to do
is solve for w right you want to find
some solution w
that would following this chain of
implications that would give you a good
cluster
so of course you could try some kind of
you can you can use whatever polynomial
solving method you want
uh to try to solve for w but we will be
able to give one which exploits the
existence of a sum of a certain sum of
squares proof the one we discussed
on the first part of the talk the sum of
squares algorithm
gives you a semi-definite programming
relaxation
for this the non-convex set of w's which
satisfy
this polynomial inequality right that's
some crazy non-convex set my point my
goal is to find some w in it
so squares gives me actually a family of
increasingly
tight stp relaxations of that set
now of course a priori an sdp relaxation
of
some crazy non-convex set might not
actually have anything to do
with the with the non with the set that
you want right it might not be good
enough
to find just some uh some stp
satisfiable solution
if you really wanted one of these
integral w's
the role of the sum of squares
identifiability proof that i'd be
labored so heavily
is that it turns out to be a dual
solution to this semi-definite program
and if you've worked with convex
programs you maybe have seen that you
can use dual solutions to
prove non-trivial facts about feasible
points in
your convex set in this case stp
solutions
and what this dual solution will show is
that
actually any solution any any relaxed
solution
any point in this stp relaxation of this
crazy non-convex set
goes to a ground truth cluster so we
knew that the integral points were close
to ground truth clusters that was
identifiability the sos proof of
identifiability means that not just the
integral points but
all of the points in the convex set are
actually close to ground truth clusters
that's uh that means that we arrive at
the kind of algorithm that i was
describing to john
um which is basically this we solve this
stp which will turn out to be some kind
of gigantic clustering stp gigantic but
still polynomial size
and we're able to basically just output
the
whatever our sdp solver returns
lastly in in two minutes i want to say
something about the
actual kind of probability content of
our paper
where we prove this identifiability fact
right so this is actually
a quite non-trivial fact about gaussians
that if you take
a list of samples from a mixture of two
gaussians
in any of these kind of challenging
situations that we have to deal with
that there is no way to take a collect
take a subset of those samples
and make it look gaussian without it
actually being one of the ground truth
clusters
so let me briefly sketch what we do to
prove this
we start by showing that this
clusterability condition
that the total variation distance
between the two underlying gaussians is
high
actually implies that that one of three
possibilities must obtain
so that we will we will relate total
variation distance to some
geometry of the underlying gaussians
what we show is that either
there has to be some direction where the
gaussians are
separated along that along some
hyperplane where separated means
that the distance between the centers is
much larger than
the variance or the standard deviation
of the gaussians in that direction
or possibility two is that the gaussians
you know they could have the same center
but there's some direction in which the
variance of one of the gaussians is much
higher than the variance of the other
or if these two possibilities do not
happen
then you basically have to be in
something like the concentric circles
situation where uh
if you amass the difference in variances
across many directions
you see separation between the gaussian
so formally the
distance between the covariance matrices
is large in frobenius norm
after you do some kind of affine
transformation to bring things into
isotropy
so basically what this means one a
different way to think about it which
was brought up during pravesh's talk
is that in each of these cases there is
some kind of polynomial test function
which distinguishes between the
gaussians in this case it will basically
will be something about the projection
onto this hyperplane
in this case it will be something about
the projection in this direction
in this case
um sam i think you i think you fell off
i guess we can uh
provide some entertainment uh in the in
the interim
uh he's uh he's no longer among the
participants yeah okay he'll probably be
back
he said at the beginning that he had an
unstable
a potentially unstable connection so
okay sounds good
it was getting so close to the punch
line of the dog
yeah this is just building dramatic
tension that's right
zoom did some updating thing to me uh
i'm very sorry about that everyone but
luckily i was basically
done um so we show
that in each of these possible cases if
my set of samples s
is split across the true clusters we
can't set our slides so
yeah yeah i'm um i'm sharing them right
now all right
just you uh in each of these cases if
the set of samples is split across the
clusters
then um there's some polynomial whose
moments
look non-gaussian so you know you can
imagine
that in for instance this case where i'm
looking at
a pair of gaussians where one has much
higher variance than the other
then the moments of the set s projected
in this direction
will violate gaussian-ness in some way
even if you look only the first few
moments
so uh that's all i want to say about
this algorithm
um i know i used up a lot of my time but
if people are willing to stick around i
can be around for questions
so thank you all for your attention um
yeah that's all
sorry i have a question the last
maybe we should thank the speaker yeah
uh go ahead john
so i'm sorry uh yeah no problem no in
the last
probability estimate to say that no n
over two
size of cluster satisfies gaussian
moments yeah you prove that by
a simple union branch or there's
something more sophisticated going on
yeah great question so we do not prove
this by a simple union bound
and actually uh there's some it's it's
probable that you could prove it by a
simple union bound
but that kind of argument is doesn't
really translate to
uh sum of squares proofs very well
because
you know if we wanted uh yeah some
somehow that kind of union bound
argument doesn't really work in sum of
squares
and we really need to make an argument
based on moments so
we do you know we apply some kind of
simple union bounds to say that
the first you know 10 or 15 moments or
something like that
of of each of the ground truth clusters
concentrates right we draw polyd samples
so that uh
you know the first the first 001 moments
are concentrated for each of the ground
truth clusters
but then we make some we make some
different kind of arguments so for
instance
in this case where the variances are
separated um
we argue that that any distribution
which
uh has something like 10
i think yeah 10 will work for something
like 10 gaussian moments
if it has a certain number of samples
in some small interval like this set s
does
then its variance must be small
that's actually like a like an
anti-concentration statement
about gaussians but the variance of this
set would have to be large because it
actually contains samples from the pink
gaussian which are far from
far from zero so we make those kind of
moment based arguments
not not a union bound that's actually
quite important for being able to do
this proof in sum of squares
sorry i'm still a bit positive by unibod
i mean presumably you need to rule out
many choices of
how to take the subset of s right yes
how do you rule out all of them
simultaneously what you are describing
seems to say that for as specific as
there are ways to detect if i understand
i don't know whether i missed already
but uh
you know let me let me try again i think
i'm not being very clear
so
i mean we have to argue that
you know the point that i think the
question is just where the union bound
happens so
imagine that we can establish some
deterministic properties of the samples
right in this case they will be that the
samples uh
the moments of the samples concentrate
and then we prove
that as long as those deterministic
properties hold
then we get a then we can give a for all
quantifier over s
right like it's the same it's the same
thing as saying that
if you have a distribution if you have a
set of samples with bounded covariance
right so if i draw enough samples my
covariance matrices will concentrate
then every subset of half of the samples
also has bounded covariance
right that's a that's a that's a true
fact about all subsets of half the
samples of a bounded covariance
distribution
but i don't have to prove it by taking a
union bound over all subsets of half the
samples i can do it by just
establishing that the covariance matrix
concentrates
and maybe okay i guess for that i maybe
need the fourth moment to concentrate
does that make sense
yes thanks
are there other questions
uh i guess i already kind of asked the
question but maybe you can
briefly elaborate uh it does seem like
the methods
uh that i have seen they always rely on
moments of the distribution so is that
is there work on doing something for
heavy tail distributions
uh you mean like for this clustering
problem
uh i guess so but but maybe even for um
[Music]
just basic parameter estimation
so let's see i mean uh there are these
papers
i guess i'm not i'm not completely sure
what you're what you're asking are you
asking whether you can use these
kind of sum of squares techniques to
hand to do parameter estimation of such
distributions
uh yes yeah okay yes
um there's a couple of
papers from the last couple years
where we used these methods to get do
parameter estimation for heavy-tailed
distributions um and there
yeah exactly you you have to you use
polynomials
um how to put this sorry
in those cases we use some kind of anal
some kind of robustified analogs of
moments
right so as you're pointing out if
things are heavy-tailed you don't want
to look at moments
instead you want to look at some kind of
robustification of them like maybe you
want to look at quantiles
or maybe you want to look at some like i
don't know huber loss applied to
apply to your moments or something so
this
there's some line of papers there's a
paper by me a couple years ago on
estimating the mean of heavy tail
distributions and then we had some paper
in stock this year on estimating
covariance of heavy tail distributions
and for those a big innovation was how
to encode using these sum of squares
polynomials
how to encode quantiles instead of
moments
i see so in that case the coefficients
of your pi
are dependent on the quantiles in some
way
i should have in mind yeah not not
quite actually what we do is we use
you know we we somehow use the
polynomials to count how many
how many samples are in some interval uh
okay
so like like if you like if you require
if you have some selector variables
right and the selector variables are
supposed to select the samples that are
in the interval minus 10 to 10
right then you can impose polynomial
constraints and say please turn this
variable on set it to one
only if this sample falls in the range
minus 10 to 10.
and you know being less than minus 10 or
being bigger or being bigger than minus
10 and less than 10 those are
polynomials in the samples
but somehow you can use the interaction
between 0 1 variables and the samples to
simulate
non-polynomial things nicely i see
okay thanks um does anyone else have a
question
uh okay so if not then uh tsuya is going
to host a
short reception on gather town
afterwards so anyone who wants to go
there the link is in the chat
so hopefully